hello and welcome to the winter 2011
edition of rochford district matters the
information paper for the people of
rochford district
in this edition are articles on how ravs
can help you help others this christmas
the chairman's year
getting ready for winter weather
a new poster design competition and much
more but we'll start with details about
the olympic torch coming to raleigh
the olympic flame is set to come to
raleigh next year as part of its journey
to the capital on friday the 6th of july
the torch will be in rayleigh and you
will have your chance to come and see
the flickering symbol which epitomizes
the spirit of the biggest sporting
spectacle in the world
in each location the flame will be
carried by specially selected
torchbearers each with their own unique
story to tell
the announcement of where the torch
would visit took place at the hadley
mountain viking olympic venue in
november and a host of sporting and
cultural events is currently being
arranged to coincide with the flames
visit to the region
the chair of the london organising
committee of the olympic and paralympic
games known as locog sebastian co said
we are thrilled to confirm that raley
will act as a host location for the
olympic flame this is the uk's moment to
shine and i want to encourage people
across rochester district to start
planning how they can be part of this
once in a lifetime opportunity and show
their support for the inspirational
torchbearers chosen to carry the olympic
flame as we count down to the start of
the olympic games
locog has worked closely with numerous
organizations across southeast essex to
devise the route for the torch relay
which is being sponsored by coca-cola
lloyd tsb and samsung
the 70-day olympic torch relay will
start at land's end cornwall on the
morning of 19th may 2012
on leaving land's end it will travel an
estimated 8 000 miles around the uk
giving thousands of communities and
individuals a chance to be part of
olympic history
around 8 000 torch bearers will carry
the flame which will travel on a host of
alternative methods of transport as it
makes its way around the country
on the final day of the torch relay july
27 2012 it is hoped the flame will
travel down the river thames towards the
olympic stadium for the lighting of the
cauldron at the opening ceremony
signifying the official start of the
london's 2012 olympic games
sebco says this is the uk's moment to
shine and i want to encourage people
across rochefort district to start
planning how they can be part of this
once in a lifetime opportunity and show
their support for the inspirational
torchbearers chosen to carry the olympic
flame as we count down to the start of
the olympic games
there's lots of events planned to
celebrate the torch relay but we want to
know what you want to do email your
ideas to leisure
rochford.gov dot uk
the citizens advice bureau cab
helps people resolve their legal money
and other problems by providing free
confidential independent and impartial
advice and information
rochford and rayleigh cab is one of
395 bureaus across england and wales all
of them registered charities
cabs are here to help everyone whoever
you are and whatever the problem
nearly half the population has used
their service at some point in their
lives and 97 percent know who they are
advisors can write letters and make
phone calls to service providers on
their clients behalf
they can help people prioritize debts
and negotiate with creditors they can
also refer clients to specialist
caseworkers in appropriate cases
initial assessments are also available
by telephone on zero eight four four
four double seven zero eight zero eight
visit www.adviceguide.org.uk
for initial information on a variety of
aspects of daily living
the cab is a free service to clients
they receive funding from rochford
district council but rely on donations
from local organizations and individuals
if you'd like more information on how
you can help or you're able to donate to
the bureau contact sue murray on
one seven zero two
five four one eight one eight
sue dot murray at rochford cab.org dot
uk or at the civic suite hockley road
rayleigh ss6
the current opening hours for initial
assessments are as follows
batlane rochford ss41ay
is open on tuesdays and thursdays from
10 a.m to 2 p.m
the rayleigh office at civic suite
hockey road raleigh ss6 8 eb
is open on monday thursday and friday
from 10 to 2.
with the cold winter months coming up a
concern for many people is likely to be
how to pay for fuel
citizens advice is currently
spearheading the formation of oil clubs
these are local or national buying
groups or cooperatives whose members
club together to buy oil
making use of discounts offered by oil
distributors to those who buy in bulk
all those in the oil group benefit from
the discount regardless of the actual
volume they choose to order
for more information on this visit
www.citizensadvice.org dot uk
forward slash oil clubs
rayleigh rochford and district
association for voluntary services ravs
based at 105 a rayleigh high street has
served the residents and community
groups of the whole of rochford district
for more than 20 years
it manages raab's volunteer center which
is quality accredited to volunteering
england
the centre matches you the volunteer
with roles which suit your personality
skills and needs with christmas
approaching there are a number of
one-off roles which you may want to
become involved in as well as those
needing more regular commitment
you can volunteer from as little as one
hour a month to much much more rafs
currently has details on more than 200
different opportunities with 90
organizations so there's something for
everyone
volunteering is a great way of becoming
involved in your local community and you
can gain a great deal of satisfaction
knowing you're making a difference
if you're part of a community group
that's looking for volunteers rafs want
you to get in touch there's never been a
better time to recruit volunteers
rafs receives inquiries about
volunteering by people with a diverse
range of skills and talents looking to
help organizations like yours
whatever your need amanda harris and
jeanette helsin are available five days
a week to answer your volunteering
inquiries
you can call them on zero one two six
eight double seven two seven nine six
online www dot ravs rrav
dot uk
by email volunteering at ravs.u.co.uk
or you can visit them at 105 high street
raley ss67qa
and ravs is looking to hear from
community groups trying to find funding
the organization has a funding officer
shelly hall who has access to
information on a wide range of grants
and can tell you what's available and
whether your group is eligible to apply
grants can be as small as 100 pounds or
as much as 500 000 pounds
contact shelley today you might be
missing out on funding that your group
desperately needs in order to continue
providing its services
watchful district sports awards 2011.
a huge audience gathered at the mill
arts and events centre for the fourth
rochford district sports awards
sponsored by virgin active nearly 200
guests heard stories of outstanding
contributions by the very best of the
sporting talent in the district at the
ceremony which was compared by bbc
essex's ben fryer the winners in each
category were sports personality of the
year sponsored by wells legal solicitors
and worlds legal homes
phillip harper swimming
disability sports personality of the
year sponsored by waters and stanton plc
jojo cranfield also swimming
young sports personality of the year
sponsored by southend united community
and educational trust
danny reason for karate
surfer sister sport sponsored by the
cooperative funeral care doug drake
swimming rochefort 2012 respect award
sponsored by mother scrubbers
rayleigh state council skateboarding
sports club of the year sponsored by
fountains stanbridge united football
club for football
the rochefort district council
chairman's award jason ox
the chairman of roxford district council
councillor simon smith said all of the
winners and the nominees deserve praise
for representing the district with such
distinction in their chosen sports
it's been a wonderful evening and we've
heard some truly inspirational stories
from all those who have taken part i
look forward to seeing how their careers
develop and wish them continued success
in the future
if you run a local business and want to
help our sporting stars visit www dot
shop at
mylocal.com forward slash
star at my local to find out more about
our star at my local scheme and current
sponsors
rochford enjoys another successful art
trail the town of rochford hosted arts
exhibitions in shops cafes and public
spaces in october for the third rochford
art trail
65 artists exhibited in 34 premises and
businesses who took part reported an
increase in visitors to the area
annette sammons of rochford archery said
there were certainly more people around
the town people discovered my business
for the first time and the artist
exhibiting at my business sold a large
artwork it's really positive for the
town and the local community
the art trail offered opportunities for
residents and visitors to get involved
through artist talks demonstrations and
family art workshops in schools and
rochford library
shop at my local
this partnership delivers a range of
projects and assistance that encourages
residents and businesses to buy locally
and regularly use local supply chains
the campaign ensures the district's
shopping areas meet their full potential
by creating thriving community centres
that offer an enjoyable shopping and
social experience
it aims to deliver initiatives and
events that attract people to the
district's main shopping areas
become a forum to engage shoppers and
traders in discussion
help to provide an opportunity to get
all opinions heard when thinking about
the main shopping areas and their
development
make it easier to access money and staff
to make the shopping areas better
help to make the shopping areas cleaner
more environmentally friendly and nicer
places to be
but how will may it being a member
actually benefit you well firstly
membership is free
once you've joined you have access to
information on the website showing you
all the vouchers and offers that are
available at shops within the district
shops you may be using already without
using the discount
you will also have access to
competitions news from the district and
local information since august 2009 shop
at my local has provided residents and
businesses of the rochford district with
a variety of projects and schemes in
order to keep people shopping locally
from free training for businesses to
offering shoppers a variety of discount
vouchers to spend in their local shops
in 2010 shop at my local won the
regional stages of the enterprising
britain competition in recognition of
its work encouraging more local spend in
rochford district
to date there are nearly 600 shoppers
signed up to the scheme and more than
400 traders
rochford district council has recently
recruited a brand new economic
development team who are keen to develop
the shop at my local project
the team consisting of jody owens hughes
economic development officer peter
bramley business support officer and
cara elliott economic development
assistant kick started the scheme at
christmas light events throughout the
district
if you want to find out more
if you want to sign up or if you want to
discuss any other business matters then
don't hesitate to contact zero one seven
zero two
three one eight one double one or email
business
rochford.gov dot uk
and visit www.shopatmylocal.com
to find out more and sign up today